greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by on it eyelid supplements in fact I
ordered mine for the month today I'm
running a little late I got the Mexican
chocolate protein I got a little shrimp
export a little shrimp tech immune and
that's it I'm tip-top Magoo ready to go
listen alpha brain the best stuff you
could take get your mind thinking if you
don't like it don't work for you
and it'll give you a money-back hundred
percent money-back guarantee no no no
questions asked alright we don't even
want the product that's how much we
believe in alpha brain so do yourselves
a favor go to Hana calm right now take a
look at the supplements to weights and
kettlebells you like something on the
way out press in church ban and you get
yourself 10% off delivery right the
house me and my men mister soupy were
talking about geez my favorite gear is a
[ __ ] Fuji I love it they've been
around since Johnny soccer more you know
what Johnny soccer more is neither do I
blue gives a [ __ ] what I'm trying to
tell you is it's a toughest guy out
there they got mats they got shin guards
they got they got kettlebells that you
don't need [ __ ] weights to they got
everything over there Fuji sports calm
so go to Fuji sports order a nice ski on
the way out press Church and get 10% off
to live at the house is that too much
the [ __ ] ass when you savages kick
this [ __ ] melee Jesus Christ I went
to the party there was a source party at
the car museum down on Fairfax and
Wilshire I went that night me and a
couple of my friends and we pulled up
and we knew this girl Kidada Jones who
worked for source or had something to do
with the party and she came out and she
was gonna bring us in and we were
walking in and honestly it was a [ __ ]
scary party it was like gang bangers
everywhere and we kind of went this
isn't a party we need to go to and we
split and the next day we heard but he
died he was murdered
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah when you felt
what you felt that in the air it was a
it was a bad vibe man it was just it was
just a bunch of legitimately tough dudes
who were looking to have a problem with
somebody you know they weren't happy
nobody was having fun it was a bunch of
people posturing and going like I'm a
murderer and I'll [ __ ] you up don't look
at me you know
it's not that's not what you wanted
apart it's not a healthy environment
Phil I don't think I've even been to a
party like how do you recognize it
you know you walk up to a party and
there's 50 dudes standing outside who
are all big guys who all have very angry
scowl on their face and they're looking
at you like do something so I can [ __ ]
you up that's how you know this is not
the party for me you know I don't know
how many buildings I walked in as well
as a young kid stupid naive to get drugs
with 800 oz in my pocket and a title
money to me at the time but it's a lot a
lot of money to somebody else sure and
you're walking up two flights of steps
and you know on the second floor there's
somebody shooting in the [ __ ] corner
they know what are you going in that
building for you know and all sudden you
hear a little [ __ ] whistle in the air
it's it's so weird you know when you're
walking into a trap
I haven't walked into a trap in a long
time it's been 10 15 years I mean one
time in the Bronx it's a kid my mother
gave me 20 bucks 10 bucks or something
and said go around the corner and buy a
toy I had to be five six and I saw
six-year-olds that didn't look like me
and didn't look like the six year olds I
play with and they knew they were gonna
chase me I was not the [ __ ] toy store
two minutes and they were chasing me
though I ran thought I'd [ __ ]
drycleaner and then you know you know
where you belong and you know where you
don't belong it's a weird [ __ ] thing
yeah is it surprising to you guys that
it doesn't seem to happen more in Vegas
well yeah I don't really hear that often
about people getting well they don't
listen Vegas police Vegas the casinos
will try to hide that so people go to
Vegas right yeah they're not gonna
[ __ ] they're not gonna you know it
they give you the news you want to hear
there's also a lot a lot of money in
tourism and a lot a lot of influence to
keep that as you know
as much as they can keep that kind of
[ __ ] at bay because it would [ __ ] with
their profits so I don't think they're
gonna allow that much awful [ __ ] to
happen in Vegas I mean obviously if we
go back to the the shooting at the
country hop concert
that's pretty terrible but that's that's
not frequent in Vegas well now they're
prepared for it yeah now that'll never
happen again in Las Vegas nobody was
ready for something like that right but
it's so weird how I think of Las Vegas
that's the macro you know how in college
you have micro and macroeconomics turn
think of Vegas think of the casino now
let's take it back to the micro of that
which is a bat which is let's just
pretend for the sake of Washington
Heights in 1985 in New York the people
will know what I'm talking about
the Dominicans had taken over the
[ __ ] neighborhood from 85 to 93 and
96 and all you had to do is get off that
bus and Port Authority and walk down the
stairs and make a left and you could buy
dirty that I was worth or $300,000 worth
now you walk out of there
Ethan is working a play in New York City
Ethan wants to get a package couple
other people on the plane want to get a
package I'm gonna go get a package I'm
going up there with 1,200 hours in my
pocket for the weekend okay so as soon
as I walked on that block Lisa at you're
gonna see spotters I'm all the corners
okay you're gonna see a guy you don't
see two guys drinking a beer they to you
when your mind they're just too [ __ ]
the street guys so the drinking of beer
over there minding their business that's
fathers they're watching the
neighborhood in 100 yards down the
corners two more spotters and six
hundred yard radius their spotters you
know why because the building is the
investment so what happens is Lisa at
who lives in 904 what the [ __ ] is nine
one for Rochester [ __ ] County that's
where white kids have money and they
come over with 1200 every Friday that's
just you think that all the thousands of
kid who come over that bridge every
Friday to get the high premium cocaine
that's the micro economic to the
Las Vegas you you're guaranteed walking
drive getting out of your car
Tom Ethan take a ride around the corner
meet me in five minutes me going
upstairs picking up a now it's running
right downstairs and get in the car with
Ethan I'm safe because all those
spotters are protecting that investment
yeah
do they have spotters like up the roads
like let them know what cars are coming
or is it just everything spiders are
everywhere to let the law but the heat
competition and the customers and and
within that community nobody is going to
risk stealing from you because you're
actually damaging the big corporation
you see what I mean so sure [ __ ] will
happen probably you know you walk around
by the way I hyperventilate walking down
if you have to walk from one casino to
the other because getting in a car is
gonna take longer so you walk and you're
just constantly in a horde of people and
it's the worst possible feeling for sure
dirty [ __ ] happens out there but there's
also tons of cops and tons of people and
they know if they see if you get robbed
walking from one casino to or another
you're stealing from the casino and
you're gonna get [ __ ] so it's that
that's the micro thing of a small drug
neighborhood and the macro is a
neighborhood like Vegas if kids start
getting boosted going to buy drugs right
those people if right now word gets out
on the street that every time I go in
the EM Jim and I go upstairs I get
robbed by my car
you're not gonna gamble at the MGM
though right absolutely you know there's
people who there's people who go to Las
Vegas and they go to casinos with it's a
million dollars just to get in there and
say I'm like you have to go credit that
and give them billion dollars just so
that they feel safe they feel safe if I
if I was a millionaire and I went to
gamble in Las Vegas you wouldn't see me
at no low-end casino you would see me a
casino with three dudes with [ __ ] a
arse at the door gambling chicks with a
bikini [ __ ] passing out cigars light
them for you copping feels they don't
give a [ __ ] about Harvey Weinstein they
never heard of I walk because every time
you grab you till they give you $1,000
oh my god yeah that's what it is that's
what reality is and I mean it has good I
it like is that ever get frustrating I
was like a criminal because you must see
I see people there all the time with
money hanging out them drunk like it
must be it would be easy oh you know
what a casino has a thousand eyes right
even if I pickpocket even before I hit
that door they're gonna grab it and and
and yeah anything that's happening is
probably happening with without violence
you know what I mean right
like this guy Apollo Robbins you heard
him he was the the top pickpocket you
know I think now he like works for the
government in in designing you know CIA
identities or something I don't know
what he does now exactly but he's like
the top he was the top pickpocket he's
done TED talks and he could he could he
could rob you without the cameras even
seeing it it looks like you had a
friendly interaction you have no idea
what happened and now he's got your
wallet so [ __ ] like that probably is
happening but they're not gonna
advertise that but you just feel like
you're drunk an you lost your watch or
something well they're gonna take care
of it's not gonna make the [ __ ] paper
you know right things have we read what
we were it's like right now look for 20
years
comedy was whatever Comedy Central gave
you all suck a bunch of podcasters
started getting a little [ __ ]
notoriety not Comedy Central's got egg
on their face because they didn't show
the real deal makes you think a lot
about music yeah do we see the real deal
of music or is what the label or what
The Times called for was there a band
out there that was better than Led
Zeppelin was there a band out there that
was better than Black Sabbath we didn't
get to see them so it's the same with
news especially now you know you watch
60 you watch the world lose tonight
which I watch every [ __ ] night the
chick I started watching with Diane
Sawyer
there they're programmed for 48 minutes
of horror yeah and then the last 12 is
somebody who's making baskets and Kansas
and making money and the [ __ ]
Japanese came up one arm who plays the
drums in a big band because he can play
with his mouth and stay you know
did they give you eight minutes of
happiness come that's
what the show is like it compels you
come back and we'll tell you about the
passenger who saved the plane from going
you know now they have this information
could you imagine if I played circle
let's say when the Chinese guy got beat
up on United right let's say if the
camera footage before the footage would
come out if United will it call CBS NBC
Fox and [ __ ] whatever and said look I
got 10 million for we use to [ __ ] pay
that tape and never play it and Chinese
guy has a press conference but there's
no [ __ ] tape no way you know I would
go for something like that I believe
something like that could happen well
that's kind of what I was just gonna say
like they picked the news yes it's
selective they picked the news but even
just what happened in Seattle where that
guy stole the plane even though the knew
I didn't hear it on the news online I
heard like the him talking with the air
traffic control oh yeah we got great
footage of it we had everything we would
have needed from the news online right
that was the weirdest thing that
happened Friday night cuz I was doing
comedy in Kansas City which I want to
thank you if you came out to the shows
and Kent City [ __ ] great audiences
you guys saw I took the [ __ ] ride
with his the city was great the barbecue
was great everything was great I came
back to my room Friday night I'm going
I'm watching what I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm
Netflix and I checked Twitter at like
1:00 and some [ __ ] people talking
about this thing and one guy says you
know it's still too early for a comedian
to make a joke about something like this
so I thought and look at the guys page
and it says comedian I go back I know
it's probably it's never too early first
of all huge comedian and if you're
thinking that way you're not really a
[ __ ] comedian because a comedian
takes social things like that and turns
it around into what I mean there was
just a bunch of ever since Mauro Ranallo
did the thing about him having the
disease you know it's like or his
followers that they can follow Mauro and
they were all like sympathizing really
quick I'm a comedian Doug whatever the
[ __ ] I'm gonna say I'm gonna [ __ ] say
it
timing is everything in comedy you know
that question pops up what is it too
soon it's never [ __ ] too soon it's
too soon whoever thinks whoever has the
biggest dick in the room first is gonna
drop that [ __ ] bomb the quickest
some people gonna react to it some
pirate a [ __ ] in the horrible brilliant
joke the other day I had one of the most
brilliant horrible jokes I've ever heard
in my life
Kevin Nealon goes what do you guys think
about the [ __ ] board day and
thickness on the [ __ ] she goes what I
heard I didn't really [ __ ] I'm like the
guy cuz I didn't wake the [ __ ] guy I
mean the audience just froze I froze
yeah
I would name the saying like that
because I don't like the guy but then I
guess I started thinking about it and I
got something in common with the guy cuz
he didn't like himself either oh my god
how brilliant of a joke is that yeah he
goes now I can't stop watching because I
wish they pick him up for another season
now Jesus just brilliant brilliant well
what the [ __ ] you want me to tell you
right but we live in such a and there
was no [ __ ] in that room that night
they took the ride with what the you
know talking about the internet like
this like we have much guys like you are
now doing this getting much more
notoriety than maybe you would have had
when it was just Fox and CBS and and
Comedy Central when when the only outlet
for comedy was force Comedy Central yes
it's much better now but also we have
the situation where you know prior to
the internet you had one politician get
up and say something slightly snarky
about another politician then you had to
wait for the next politician to get a
news conference together to make a
retort which just upped it a little bit
so it would take six months before
they're actually in a big fight and now
the level of hostility in America is
ramped so high you have you know
Republicans are all Nazis and Democrats
are all communists and you have
everybody trying to shut everybody down
with intense hostility and there's this
kind of like people are getting off on
being outraged and I think that's not
productive it's not it's not productive
at all the internet is killing us slowly
it's giving us too much information at
I agree we're having too much [ __ ]
information and and just like drugs just
like alcohol just like exercise just
like chicken cutlets you have to give it
a breather from day of the day you have
to really like that's why on the
weekends I have a very low once Friday
comes I try to stay off the internet as
much as I can till Monday morning yeah
it's too much internet and you read a
lot of [ __ ] you shouldn't and sometimes
you're going a fox hole or videos or
something like that that you shouldn't
be watching it has nothing to do with
your life you know you can't even on the
computer I take it on the road I don't
have Twitter and Facebook right I have
my hotmail and I have writing apps and I
have Netflix that I do have but I wanted
to give it a break I got an iPad my wife
got there's no reason yeah give Facebook
a [ __ ] breathe it's so easy to get
riled up and it's too much and that's
just you know you Facebook and Twitter
they great for six or seven weeks and
then you get one week where you get all
hate yeah and you're like where's this
hay coming from there's a reddit thing
that this is you know you know what it
makes you want to get the [ __ ] off there
but there's so many good people on there
that follow you and that interact with
you that you feel for them but the
Internet has just given a voice to a lot
of it's given me a voice in a positive
manner but it's given people a voice in
a negative manner yeah the the ability
to highlight one sentence or one action
from a person's life in the past and and
put a microscope on that thing and and
to call their entire existence this
action or this statement that happened
years ago
that's a weird that's a weird dangerous
thing to do that's a very odd power to
hold over somebody you know what I mean
we're living in weird times I'm an
immigrant and as you know I did time in
fact Wednesday is a 30th anniversary of
me getting sentenced Congrats
you never said me you've never said me
you've never heard me say the word Pig
waiting negative about cops I put myself
where I put myself I'm gonna tell you
something Nathan suply on that dad did
something very bad
I took somebody against their world
world machine gun and I handcuffed them
when I was running from day one if you
want me to why the entire I was a victim
and I know about the trunk in the car
and then we weren't gonna kill him we're
gonna put him on a bus to Arizona it was
one guy that was doing it for a stripper
and the other guy was just doing it to
get $30,000 I just want to get my hands
on thirty thousand bucks
I thought $30,000 would bring all the
happiness in the world to me at that
time oh boy was that [ __ ] wrong but
let's be honest I'm not the same person
I was dirty is it that's what I mean so
what's going on now is a [ __ ]
embarrassment because I was raised in
the country I was raised to believe that
your [ __ ] I sent to prove the [ __ ]
guilty but if Greg Garcia says that we
went to college together in Virginia one
that put my finger up his [ __ ] I lose
everything I have because Greg Garcia
says I put my finger up his [ __ ] 1980
well guess what Greg Garcia was a
different person 1980 and [ __ ] so
were you maybe you wanted somebody to
stick a finger in your [ __ ] you used
to remember now Holden that's what I
mean that's what I'm saying beyond all
that even were human beings so you know
I I'm not a Christian but I think one of
Jesus's principle teachings was that
we're all flawed you know what I mean
every human being is flawed so like as
long as that's the foundation from where
we start our arguments or fights in our
outrage with people is that we're all
flawed everyone's flawed so if somebody
did something that you consider more
flawed 20 30 years ago where's the
avenue to correct that are we just
excising it and pretending that that
shit's never gonna happen again or are
we gonna talk about like how do we fix
this problem do you know what I mean I I
mean I don't even know what I James Gunn
said I didn't even read what he said but
I heard got fired for something he said
on Twitter 10 or 15 years ago or
something like that can't the guy just
say you know like I'm embarrassed by
what I said I did
know what I was doing sorry I offended
people I'm gonna work to not offend
people in the future like isn't that a
more sane way to deal with that we live
in strange times
social media is everything now you know
we learned a big lesson through the Rose
Ann thing whether she did the ambien or
not or whatever I have a problem I had
with no one but right now I have at the
one with that I'm 55 with stand-up comic
I have a podcast I want to do comedy
I'm leaving the same person I was 10
years ago because I was running drugs 10
years ago but today I smoked pot like I
was telling the audience in Kansas to
them all those guys that's sober but not
really like I smoked pot I mean inedible
if you have it from time to time to be
sharable if I cannot [ __ ] pop it it's
not that I'm gonna eat these things all
the time but I'm definitely not the same
person he was 11 years ago
I totally if we had this podcast 11
years ago his podcasts would have never
made it because I wouldn't have showed
up at 6:00 in the morning
I was too paranoid to leave the [ __ ]
house at 6:00 in the morning so I don't
like that I don't like what's going on
in that realm where somebody could come
up that's why when I do this podcast I
tell people everything I've done right I
think that's the only way to bulletproof
your system I mean if you're a very open
person so I have to yeah today's world I
knew that I knew that this was gonna
trigger some people so before anybody
would say something I might as well say
it and it makes me vulnerable I want you
to know about my life for two reasons I
want you know about my life and I want
you to know that no matter what the
lemon you get yourself out into you'd
get yourself out yeah I'm no [ __ ] fun
way to Cap'n
yes I am Phi Beta Kappa I quit high
school and I got left back in the
seventh grade
and somewhere another I figured that I
never left I kept getting on that
[ __ ] stage I didn't give a [ __ ] that
I didn't go to Montreal [ __ ] what you
thought I'm telling you that I'm gonna
do this and I kept doing it I kept
showing up that's all
yeah I didn't do anything else that
nobody ever did by the way how the [ __ ]
did you get into act no Juilliard no
nothing no no no nothing living out here
I
I dropped out of school when I was 14 I
had a buddy who I knew kind of who was
an actor and I was like you know if you
can do that and like nobody's gonna give
you [ __ ] about being in school because
you're you're working like I might as
well try and do that and that's what I
did and I basically started working when
I was 16 she sat out this whole time all
these years I know you for some reason I
thought you had grown up in New York say
like you were a PS 19 type of guy and
then you went to Julliard
like I always I don't know why I had put
this fake biography laughing I got like
an actor cap yeah or like a [ __ ] one
of those sideways hats with a feather
and yeah you do like a play in New York
or something and somebody saw yeah you
know it's I have had a lot of guys
rapper put a lot of guys have come in
and they were all from New York for some
reason but you went to whatever school
out here yeah and then you got what was
the first thing you booked
Boy Meets World first what is your
theory Wow and you didn't stop by after
that no I did I did I did that for three
years and and like in my off time from
doing that I did a bunch of commercials
and I did them this show Tales from the
Crypt which was fun back in the early
90s and then I did Mallrats with Kevin
Smith like a year into that and then I
started doing movies what do you like
better movies of TV now that I have kids
I like TV because it's it's a schedule
that you have some prediction on it's
not like I'm going away for seven months
and I'm gonna do this movie in Romania
which I've done so I think TV and
there's there's it you know TVs another
thing that with the with the with the
advent of the Internet and we have all
this information we also have so much
television where I would say like a huge
percentage of television is better than
a lot of the movies they're making now
which is really fascinating and the
majority of the movies that they're
making now are either you know there's
some cool independent films and then
there's like you know transformer six
that's kind of
what you have in movies and and from
when I was coming up in the 90s we had
this Renaissance of indie film with guys
like Quentin Tarantino and I think all
of that is now on television which is
great
that's crazy you're saying that cuz
television has grown leaps and bounds
yeah especially with streaming you see
so much crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] on streaming
now that you could see TV taking a mock
yeah a lot of places like just regular
home TV but I also know you from Eddie's
yeah that's how we met Aradia and I
still remember going in and reading from
My Name Is Earl mancine at the table
read yeah very excited and it's funny
how you were a lot bigger than yeah I
mean yeah your joint started at what at
what wait did you say when them through
with this [ __ ] man I I got together with
my wife in you know it was a weird thing
because I I had girlfriends prior to my
wife but there was always a feeling of
not belonging really for whatever reason
and then I got together with my wife in
2001 and and like one of the first
things she did was say like okay we're
together now now you're gonna get on a
diet and that was like that changed my
life and and I basically been on a diet
since then to one form or another but it
was I was probably a 500 pounds in 2001
and what he had that 300 beautiful and
I've been lower than this a few years
ago I was obsessed with riding bicycles
and I got down to 220 but I actually
felt too thin at 220
I went down at 268 my head felt really
big any high neck got really skinny and
I was going on a lot of auditions as
soon as I walk in they go through like
what the [ __ ] happened to you like yeah
you got the hit all of a sudden the [ __ ]
happens you're dying with people uh yeah
really look at you [ __ ] weird and
there's always been that weird thing
that they hire the fat guy when you're
fat knowing you lose weight you're done
like that's been the big thing in
Hollywood like you [ __ ] done yeah
you've maintained well I've gone back
and forth it was a weird thing because
when I was at 220 every day I would look
at myself and see how fat I was but I
was also racing bicycles so like the
objective there is to be as a
lightweight as possible so I would be
starving myself I would only allow
myself to eat while I'm riding the bike
I was riding eight hours a day six days
a week like gnarly rides from Studio
City to Oxnard and back and and and then
when I went when I was like I can't
maintain this because number one I'm
riding so much I can't work and number
two I'm like nobody knows me I'm so thin
now that people are when I go in to see
them people are like who the [ __ ] are
you we didn't want to meet with you
where's the guy we wanted to meet with
so then when I kind of let it all go I
gained weight and I was heavier than I
am now and it was a real weird thing
remembering being 220 and thinking I was
so grossly overweight to being 320 and
feeling great about myself you know what
I mean and like my wife just has a body
dysmorphia which I might but like I
don't feel uncomfortable in my body
today you know so did you feel
uncomfortable at 220 220 I felt pretty
fat yeah I was 9 percent body fat in the
machine like I went and saw this guy dr.
Huizenga because he was on The Biggest
Loser and he was like the top sports
nutrition guy and he [ __ ] scanned me
and he said you're done don't lose
anyway and I was like but I'm so fat and
yeah it was weird so when you look in
the mirror you saw off that guy or you
felt fat
I probably just felt that because I
don't know that I could have seen a fat
guy I don't know if that if that's
totally honest but but I definitely
didn't feel thin I never got to a place
in my entire life where I was like
that's it I don't need to lose weight
anymore what's the disease that you look
at yourself in the mirror and see
yourself at and you keep going going
going and then they have to take it to
the hospital and like I assume that's
what like anorexics experience no you
said earlier body dysmorphia body where
you look at yourself I had a friend
growing up that she went from being a
hot piece of ass to this [ __ ]
skeleton yeah but but but now it works
both ways cuz I have the reverse body
dysmorphia we're at 350 I'm like oh do
my wife like I look great I don't need
to [ __ ] diet anymore and she's like
shut the [ __ ] up
put down the cupcake you're fat it's
funny when you get body dysmorphia I get
by this morphe when I travel yeah when
you see yourself in a foreign mirror
yeah walk out of a bathroom when you're
naked you're oh [ __ ] I don't see that
what the [ __ ] does you see what you your
mind wants you to really see yeah you
see what your mind really wants you to
see when you're looking at a mirror yeah
but your mind's not always right no no
no they have skinny mirrors and hotels
is that what it is no and there's some
hotels that you you come out of the
bathroom and you look at yourself and go
wow what the [ __ ] was going on [ __ ] is
going on
oh in the bad way yeah oh you see that
thing hanging over you don't see it yes
because in your house you see what you
want to see yeah gotcha
it's a weird [ __ ] thing what diets
have you gone on just I protein I've
done and I have since I was a little kid
I've done every diet that's existed so
you've had this since oh yeah my whole
life yeah I've always been overweight um
the the the the way I eat that I find
the most sustainable is I just got rid
of anything processed
so I only really eat fruit no I don't
eat fruit I only meat and vegetables
that's it and I don't even eat starchy
vegetables so I basically eat a small
amount of salads and some meat red meat
yeah you read me I eat a lot of chicken
ate red meat turkey I eat any kind of
meat fish yeah I don't love fish but I
eat fish I mean you look yolk now you
look like you're lifting that that's all
I do I lift weights and I go on hikes
that's my exercise how many days a week
you lift it I lift five days a week
no [ __ ] yeah and I hike five days a week
when I have time
it's not another teen program is
strength or muscle base like this drink
really yeah what kind of like deadlifts
that type of [ __ ] yeah I do Olympic
lifts and then I'll I'll become obsessed
with one muscle that I want to increase
the strength in like my triceps III tore
my bicep um two years ago doing a TV
show and so I don't ever do any bicep
exercises but I do like today I worked
on triceps a lot for some reason and
traps
I always think dudes with big traps look
tough so I want big traps wolf in the
Greek body was always an X they devised
it to be an X so the traps should be
strong yeah it's really looked weird
when you look at somebody like James
Caan he's got little traps yeah the
tricep the weird thing about the tricep
is it's got three heads to it so when
you really break down bodybuilding till
your tricep you really have to hit the
tricep them three different angles cause
it's really three quarters of your arm
yeah a lot of people working on bicep
work but they really don't know that
they do like like the tricep extensions
you know these [ __ ] things yeah and
their disks with weight and then the
exercise that people really overlook
that really tears your [ __ ] upper
body is pullovers yeah porn your leg
yeah all over with a straight bar
there's a lot of weight 5 6 or 6 you do
that free year you will get [ __ ] yo
yeah you swallow a lot I haven't done
squats in a while because I had a knee
issue a few years ago so I don't do a
lot of squatting well this after 40 you
shouldn't really squat that much but you
should do the machine yeah I I tend to
just do hikes for legs and and I find
that my legs are so dead after a long
hike that I I feel like that takes the
place of actually doing resistance work
with my legs it does it's your own body
way you have to laugh a little bit and I
know you've been at it for a while
I mean I've been doing something
somewhere in 16 17 years now yeah and
when do you go to do Jitsu now Jiu Jitsu
is very very rare I'm bender Jiu Jitsu
in a while it's been it's been a while
it's time you're back yeah and I think
go back and just tell the guy what you
want to do you want to a closed guard
game yeah and I think it's good for the
mental thought I think I agree I think
it would be good to do Jiu Jitsu till
they put me in the casket yeah just to
go in there one day we get choked is
very important yeah getting choked is
very important getting know how
vulnerable you are do you remember that
British dude who fought in the UFC he
used to work out when we would train in
Hollywood um he had a mohawk I don't
remember his name party maybe so yeah
James James alright that dude choked me
out once and I knew he had me in a leg
in in a triangle choke but I thought I
could get out of it and then I woke up
it was the most bizarre I went out so
fast there was no time to tap I thought
I'm gonna work and get out of this and
then I was waking up it was real [ __ ]
weird and just so we don't get a bunch
of stuff it's Dan Hardy Dan yeah dude
nice great guy great guy
Houston barbecue with him a couple of
times you have an eddy and all those
guys that was a great group of guys when
you guys were at the corner next to the
Thai place yeah that was fun you know
Lee always asked me why don't you extend
your horizons and these different places
the audio listener should have seen the
look I remember one night I was trying
to be a nice guy and just fit in I think
I got enough to blow something and I
know let me meet these guys from 10th
planet and the you guys used to always
go next door the end of the tie place
this high place and I don't need Thai
food for many reasons I figure let me go
in there and give it a shot maybe I'm
being a [ __ ] [ __ ] and I'm not that
three [ __ ] minutes I see a roach I
saw two roaches one flew by me and one
was up in the corner like what are you
giving him what me I just want to know I
just want to know inquiring minds I know
you just sitting here with a girl right
and you want to feel you know what do
whatever you want do and there's a
cockroach you're eating food but there's
a cockroach in that corner right like
what and I'm not because they had the
suspended ceiling and the roach came out
of the ceiling
Oh what would you do you get up here's
the thing and this is what I tell my
kids I got four kids the US DEA I guess
has an allowance for Roach parts maggots
fecal matter in every bit of food at the
supermarket you don't go through one
meal without eating part of a roach or
some bug or some rat [ __ ] or something
like that and that's if they look at it
think of the places you went to overtime
victory and [ __ ] are you reading some
some all right you're eating food you
can hear you could taste the kid that
give the kids tears who lost his cocker
spaniel it upsets me because I used to
go to get dumplings in Koreatown and you
should look for one stray cat I dare you
to find one straight nothing dogs
parakeets
they're in an animal that's you know I
don't it's only you know every time I
and I gotta tell you this is the truth
today I went the strength train and I
had to do something at 12 but I didn't
have time so I went and I got chicken
and broccoli
that's his harmless activity at the
Tyler Thai place no I don't know any
Thai place I can't [ __ ] with chicken and
broccoli because it's got sugar in it at
the time this I thought I did not the
Chinese place okay
take the sugar out
yes the white wine or whatever and I got
a taste and this is a great place they
have a couple dishes of a sensation and
I'll tell you something whenever I meet
and check another Chinese restaurant I
know I'm getting something else okay
something else is in there parakeet I
paid you there's something else and
they're like they give you some chicken
but those pieces of meat that you really
can't really send is darker a little
darker than usual they just throw a
couple things in there like little game
if I actually ever found out that I ate
something like that that's when I lose a
hundred pounds because I didn't eat I
can't like I have to put that out of my
mind
yeah it's a great thing I love food so
much I want to eat pigeons I want to eat
parakeets I want to eat all of it
that's a you're opening my horizons my
foods so limited you tell me there's a
place serving great parrot I'm in oh my
god there's all these places when I was
a kid there was a place called the mai
tai we used to go to the mic I had a
[ __ ] tremendous buffet Chinese buffet
yeah
and it was stopped in the middle behind
the right side was a cemetery a [ __ ]
cemetery but half of my car we were
going to my car that was why so yes I
used to have a buddy Roger that used to
we'd catch him at the my card before
nitin giant games he'd be getting
[ __ ] tuned up and he honed the
bartender I think what the mark of his
name was doesn't matter but we walk in
have a drink and he get this is how
tuned up he had the bartender he'd go to
jail for doing this he called the
bartender and go bend open the bar
thought about this we go ah
and he just karate-chop in the neck you
gonna [ __ ] jail for that yeah they
destroy you out for [ __ ] racism he
would just give the guy like 1/10 he
goes come on show him the neck
ha and he just karate-chop the guy taken
the neck they had spare ribs oh I know
all you can eat [ __ ] buffet that was
delicious they were big spirit but they
cut him in half
yeah so you can eat me my buddy went in
there one time like pick up the [ __ ] on
one side as we were walking with the
train they changed I came out stop stop
we dined and dashed in there 80 times
growing up I can't tell you the amount
of damage how many times I want
with my mother to the mic I drunk one
day they were in there and they found
that the meat was all cats they found
the cats hanging upside down and the
grass they were putting in the [ __ ]
food was the grass in the cemetery like
these people would just [ __ ]
torturing people thank God I was twelve
fifteen when I went in there your
stomach is like a billy goat like you
don't even know what the [ __ ] you're
eating but I'm trying animals and
alligator meat and [ __ ] now although she
is you were uh you were with jiu-jitsu
whatever you made a great point before
you think you were [ __ ] you hit it
right on the spot you know you know I
enjoyed you Jitsu and everything but
it's also 2018 you know and I always go
back to that scene and Indiana Jones
well you know the guy has to soar
they're gonna do Chuck so whatever when
he comes out and he does all this thing
and Indiana Jones nothing [ __ ] even
looking takes his gun and shoots the guy
and puts the gun back in this holster
and walks away and whatever has a scene
in it
I think jujitsu is a amazing exercise
and amazing techniques for specific
situations if I'm walking back to my car
I'm just gonna avoid people and if
somebody gets close to me I don't want
to roll around with on the ground with
him if I don't know who's around me I
mean we talked about this you and I
about social anxiety constantly thinking
about who's around me and how are you
gonna guarantee if somebody blindsides
you that he doesn't have three friends
there so you you take him down into
guard one of their friends could tee off
on your head or maybe he's got a knife
those are a lot of variables for MMA
it's amazing if you're walking around in
your life on a mat and you know that
dude doesn't have [ __ ] you know mersa
or some other skin disease and you're
comfortable rolling around with him and
you want to challenge each other that's
great but I don't know about it in in
the day and age where everybody's got
guns and knives and and friends wait
on the corner and I don't go out to
situations very often when I'm around
many people cuz I don't like those
situations so I'm just never gonna get
into a fistfight like that where I would
need it do you know what I mean I
understand
hold that thought we'll put on Tony
Bennett let me go home home over 50 so I
got a Pieri for you sir let me go take a
quick beer we'll continue on that
thought it's thinking about something
yesterday I got home are they three in
the morning and there was a seminar for
Yugi to at 12:00
side control seminar and there was also
Alberto crane at 12:00 and I had a
couple of options but I only slept three
hours a night before I slept till about
1:30 and my wife came home we lunch and
she goes the baby got invited to a swim
thing do you mind if we go you know I
can do a thousand things all over the
crowd I repeat and I will know what a
weed store and I filled up the week the
car for a week and I made notes and I
was still bored and I said you know it's
four o'clock they're not gonna be able
to five three I put boxing gloves on and
I got a boxing bag in my backyard and I
went out there my started hitting it by
my side doing push-ups and sit-ups I got
a kettlebell and I did a couple swings
then I started stretching and I get up
and do them we tied drills and stuff and
as I was putting everything away I was
like you know what man that was 35
minutes I put it down Weight Watchers
and my t-shirt was really wet and I'm
like how lucky am i I'm 55 and I'm able
to move around what I know now like it's
it's it's helpful for me for calmly to
move around
I walked into a digit sister listen when
I met you and aliens I've already but I
always thought you Jitsu before people
who had the desire stick up my ass you
know I'm saying I don't know why the
yeah I don't know what that means if
somebody gets insulted I always thought
that if he won of the road so they were
all around when I got a say somebody
coming up to me and tell me they got a
man-crush what's the next you wanna suck
my dick young as I am but I walked into
a jujitsu studio and I was 49 years old
I fell in love and what really made me
fall in love with it was how bad the
shape I was in and how ill-prepared I
was
in case something did go down yeah I
don't want to be your sea fighter I do
not want to be a tough guy I do not want
to be a bully I'm gonna be none of those
things but I always want to at least
last two minutes sure if you're kicking
me and I can at least get the under hook
and grab your belt and spin you over
jiu-jitsu paid off me
do you a hundred percent I'm not
knocking known as else--if far if I
could kick him all the [ __ ] really
hard in the leg which I can it's 300
pounds coming out here I've been kicking
since I was [ __ ] 5 yeah all I got are
two good kicks but if I connect with
those two kicks I can get to my car I'm
good yeah at this age at this age when
you have to take care of yourself at the
same you know when you're gonna have 50
in a few years everything changes
everything changes you know that's why I
read up on my jiu-jitsu over 40 and I
was doing it all wrong like Monday's you
just have to be drilling and you rolled
once or twice and you leave Wednesday
you come back you drill but you roll
three times then Friday you drill less
and roll and then you take two days off
that's over 40 jiu-jitsu yeah and with
people that are not gonna get you in
heel hooks and the knee locks and all
that [ __ ] cuz you don't need that you
cannot be unemployed no yeah I'll you
cannot be mad at me sir yeah so not it's
did these all these things these aspects
but I'm happy that I'm prepared now what
are you prepared for Joey to beat me up
I didn't say that
no I'm prepared to just get to my car
before the cops get there or before
something worse could happen
sure escalates even worse I also believe
in the power of the gun I also believe I
just have the felonies and I'll never
get a license but from time to time my
friend takes me to shooting now and you
know I'm just I've been working but when
I was a kid I want to be a hit man yeah
you talked you spoke about two things
today I want to be a hit man but the
most thing I wanna be was a pickpocket
yeah there was a movie
Michael Cyrus and James Coburn then
called Harry in your pocket yeah it's
about him pickpockets at the track or
the airport or something you know
so when you mention that guy's name
before
he's amazing that guy what's his name
Apollo Robbins Apollo and you just watch
his he's got a TED talk and on his
[ __ ] TED talk he's on camera the
whole time cuz it's Ted and so they're
filming him he does he pulls off some
crazy [ __ ] which you which I then I
watched his TED talk five times because
he's just misdirecting you the whole
time while the cameras are on him and
shit's happening that you're not
noticing and then at the end he points
it all out and you're like holy [ __ ]
that guy that got being a pickpocket
loose in Las Vegas he's robbing everyone
he's robbing everyone blind and then
he's having to put on disguises because
eventually the casino figures out oh
that interaction that that's when that
guy got robbed because people go and
complain eventually when they get robbed
and I believe eventually the casinos
hired him to say what do we look for
help us find the pickpockets his amazing
guy it's nuts that a couple weeks ago I
was looking for my name is Errol you
know and I asked Lee is it still on
Netflix and he goes no it's on Hulu and
watched a few episodes and then you did
something and I laughed
you and your [ __ ] crazy brother and
then two days later he you are on blow
they've been playing on HBO lately or
something and it's the part where you
two'll the runs into [ __ ] attack I
don't look how big he is and that was
right right before I turned my life
around to that happy 98 99 something
like that I mean you were up there and
then I went online and you're talking
about being at your sister-in-laws
concert and you had your back against
the wall and all I thought you were
goofin at first you know I thought you
would goofing around at first and I hate
you back up and I go do you suffer
through that social [ __ ]
like yeah I'm looking at the doors and
my backs against the wall what's going
on and how long have you had it you know
I think that that has been a really
helpful way to deal with it if I'm at a
concert or something like that which I
would just rather not be at honestly but
I got kids and a wife and people who
like being out in public then I can just
put all of my attention on okay if
something happens here how do we get out
if I look around do I see any obvious
threats do I see any unobvious threats
like what's going on and as long as I
keep myself busy with that I'm not I'm
not I'm okay I'm kind of fine you know
as long as I have that thing to do but
just being comfortable with myself in
the presence of a lot of people I'm just
not comfortable since what for my whole
life I've never been comfortable you
know I used to like to go to punk rock
concerts a lot and there was something
about the energy and the acceptance at a
punk rock concert because there was no
there was no single group of there was
you know like you go to a hip-hop
concert and maybe you're wearing the
wrong colors and then it's an issue and
you've got a problem that that didn't
exist from from what I experienced in
punk rock in the 80s and early 90s you
just go and you have fun and you wind up
a little bit bruised but exhilarated and
and that was the closest I got to being
comfortable in a crowd but there was
some violence there you know what I mean
like there was some overt violence
happening and that was the only way that
I really felt comfortable which is kind
of depressing
I guess would you think that a couple
people got smacked so you felt right at
home maybe then maybe they got smacked
maybe I got smacked you know I was just
more comfortable with that with knowing
exactly what's gonna happen and and what
it's gonna be like and and going in
there and enjoying it I haven't
really enjoyed a concert since I was a
teenager they just make me terribly
uncomfortable being around all those
people what about at the situation's in
Vegas and all in the Florida does that
add to your honestly you'll know that
doesn't bother me I'm not worried about
I'm not worried about getting shot I'm
more I'm more just uncomfortable being
surrounded by people than I am it's not
that I'm scared of getting shot um I've
been to Vegas since then I've been to
Florida that I don't know that that
doesn't really worry me too much no how
are you in front of a camera a camera's
is I'm pretty comfortable in front of a
camera
when this forty people on a set well
I'll tell you what if we do a table
reading we sit down and and we're just
reading in front of the crew I'm
terrifically uncomfortable but once were
doing it and the cameras there those
people don't exist
it's just what were it's just this
universe that we're pretending into
existence you know what I mean
so it doesn't bother me I was having a
hard time would stand up at the store
especially anxiety yeah being in front
of a crowd like that I said that I can't
especially and I couldn't figure out why
I couldn't figure out what [ __ ] was
going on why I was I've been going to
this place I went in there to showcase
for Mitzi shore I'm already out of the
weeds why am I going in here twenty
years I have to stand up comedy that
I've been doing it this is my home and
why is it that's when I walk up five
steps this whole feeling comes over my
head so I did what everybody else in
America does I went and got xanaxs and I
would take one soon as I hit the comedy
store my heart starts pumping and I
would take one or two and as soon as I
and look for a safe passage once I don't
see a safe passage that's when I
panicked yeah right now that window has
those little blinds are the [ __ ] up
that's safe passage for sure I know that
that's a pass it's like when I go give
blood down a Bob Hope Medical Center I
don't let them take blood out at all in
a room with no windows
yeah cuz there's no safe passage for me
I've been doing comedy on my life why
does this hit me now yeah where is this
coming from now for you to type that
that night I was like this guy does
[ __ ] he's mother you know you don't I
said with Johnny Depp than 40 [ __ ]
people yeah
now you want to get this social anxiety
now but you've always had it yeah I've
never felt comfortable around around a
lot of people like that
I've always that that safe passage I've
found it's exactly the same I have to
have I'm I will literally stand in a
corner until I can figure out but it's
got for me it's slightly more literal
because I want to find an exit how if I
have to get out of here how am I gonna
do that and I'm not worried about being
shot what if the building catches fire
well you know I don't know I it's all
fantasies constantly going in my head I
just want to know how I get the [ __ ] out
of there fast now when you went to
jujitsu the first time and somebody
mounted you how did you feel oh my god
and it's not a good feeling
especially when you have that little
thing sure I made mistakes in the
beginning in jujitsu and I'm right I'll
take available and go to jujitsu oh my
god no good huh the first time suddenly
miles you and you're gonna hip escape
and hip mom they don't go nowhere
I left the tap and I had to run outside
and take my guitar off and I'd have to
pee yeah like that's how much fear I
would put myself through the first month
and a half of jujitsu if I don't go to
jujitsu for three or four days now when
I go back I still have a feeling walking
in that's why when I go in to you just
to the first time they would put my gun
and roll around with somebody yeah roll
around get beaten so breathe heavy just
he has a warm-up just it's a warm-up for
my fear sure it's a warm-up of my fear
when I go to a comedy club now I don't
bring there's an exert me now little
baby whatever the [ __ ]
one point five they give you I forced
myself to talk to people this is how I
gotta fear yeah I forced myself to talk
to people and I find something to [ __ ]
aggravate the [ __ ] out of me yeah for me
to get that little spark anger going
well I think that's that's very smart
because everything yeah anything that
can irritate you I I've honestly found
Joey through through however many years
I've been dieting and I've been sober
for a long time which I would rather not
be honestly if I'm being like completely
honest I would but I need to be you
understand but I found that everything
worthwhile is painful and if you get
into that and you somehow find a way to
enjoy that pain and that suffering then
you're just better off you you earned
the outcome you know you go into a
comedy store and you find something to
irritate you who wants to go around
being irritated nobody wants that's not
just two minutes before stage of course
too late before I go upstairs have to
find something from my past that [ __ ]
guy's got sandals on that [ __ ]
you know that the other day some guy
walked past me I was pissed because he
had body odor and I'm like that's a
hummus eater just to myself I call the
homicide and I giggle then there you go
boom I won the war yeah I just beat the
war on myself
yeah just cracking that [ __ ] joke I
even call in since then but the humba
season we were Howard he goes well
people come look at it like it being
race I don't know it was a white do but
I could think it was a [ __ ] humba see
that could smell the hummus on his neck
kind of like when he has hummus the
Flies chase him in here all the time
because they [ __ ] do you're next but
last night I was blown away I was blown
away last night because it was a
as the girls were walking in I was
scrolling I was gonna see what's on 60
minutes and then I scroll down and it
was the lap autopsy have you watched or
not called autopsy the final hours out I
saw Amy Winehouse
I saw Whitney Houston who really died no
she didn't die cocaine overdose she died
because her body was numb and when she
got into a hot tub the tub cooked up oh
really
yeah like the hot water just basically
cooked it right but she couldn't feel
you know you really learned about George
Michael but last night they had Chris
Cornell but I just had a lot like that
couple we saw they had the last days of
James Gandolfini right yeah you know you
gotta watch that one happy dude yeah but
this one was very interesting first of
all it said that she found the box of
Beatle albums we tell you son you're too
young I think you guys are too young
does anybody remember Beatle people know
like people who really are into the
Beatle I mean I know people go really
into the mic I told the story on here
before John Lennon got shot it was a
different country music couldn't you can
him Bruce Springsteen's born to run
that's a grand out yeah wait till the
Beatles get back together you know
everything was that right there was
always one [ __ ] in the room that
always had to go yeah that's good but
wait the Beatles got back together and
you would have to sit there and take it
because there were the kings at that
time sure when John Lennon got shot 20
people were [ __ ] hysterical and like
[ __ ] you and the Beatles because there
was all these Beatle fans that went
crazy right you know nobody remembers
really when Jack I love John when I
ain't say nothin bad about John with him
or when he got shot there was a lot of
things in New York I was going to New
York I've seen these people [ __ ] cry
and I couldn't understand like I giant
white John whether I like [ __ ] nah
that was so loud he made all that [ __ ]
but Jesus did people [ __ ] like upset
you know so now I I could understand the
Chris Cornell thing because I got upset
when Chris did that I got upset so I
watched
this thing last night and they showed
how he was a big beetle guy and his
parents Rockies and he was obsessed with
the beetles and he just well he was 13
14 he was already doing [ __ ] drugs
alright and when you do PCP was do what
I was doing PCP and [ __ ] angel dust
and smoking weed and tripping he was a
river big tripper and at that age when
your mental state when your your mind is
not even developed my 20 yeah
dangerous that's not bad oh you know
that's not why no so your receptors
freeze and all this [ __ ] they're
explaining all this stuff about what
serotonin and then this man how once you
do all this stuff you can you know at
the time of Chris Cornell's death he was
completely sold right there was no pills
found and it wasn't anything in xanax
something no there was nothing in there
there was nothing no alcohol no nothing
in his autopsy right they were saying
that he was slurring up on stage and
stuff like that and they just said that
it's like more Dane his suicide really
bothered me there's nothing the same
neighborhood yeah that's a Catholic
[ __ ] neighborhood G they don't
believe and take this one dies yeah so
for him to take a swan dive so I said a
little now and bam what we have in
common which is drug use prior young
drug use so for a guy like me it scares
the [ __ ] out of me
you know my wife goes to bed at 9:00 I
said one room by myself by 11 o'clock I
got a loose you know the same but they
were talking about Cornell's mind all
those years he wrote pretty noose and
fell on black days talking about his
depression so they just said that his
depression got the better half of him
that night in rats why he killed himself
when I'm petrified now now with all
these I get those you know I saw a lot
of death as a kid that's a little PTSD
ish you know yeah and the drug use you
know that that was eminent that was an
and I wanna I was tellin Lee when I was
16 or 17 and a year one time I did acid
every other day and every day masala
microdot I was selling it so I mean my
tolerance
was built from when people were taking
one hit it hasit I was taking four yeah
you familiar at all with any of the
tenants of the a a you know familiar
with a a and all yes absolutely like one
of their principles is take it a day at
a time
absolutely for me quite often I have to
I have to contract that to just getting
through a moment you know and and and if
I can decide to get through a moment I
know that there will be a moment where
I'm no longer in whatever state of
suffering that I'm in whether it's an
urge to do something I know logically to
be the wrong thing to do like drugs or
alcohol
whether it's just being overly emotional
about something wanting to make any
decision based on emotion I just get if
you just get through the painful moment
you know [ __ ] will open up you know what
I mean
I was totally a couple to little [ __ ]
short died and we took out the Bulls
dead no we had the podcast on Sunday
night and that was that of her awake at
the store and I got so much anxiety
about thinking I'm going through that
wake and seeing all those people I just
[ __ ] the bed I just decided not to go
but it was it wasn't like what went home
and I was going through this [ __ ]
mental state like just this confusion
you know she did so much for me I would
look if I didn't go down there but I
know if I went down there a guy was
gonna go down there and I was gonna pick
a fight with him he's gonna pick a fight
with me something's over happened I was
shooting that Netflix thing so I said
let me avoid this whole situation but
that night I did that whole situation
drug free like beside the edible I can't
even do anything else that night are you
at what I'm saying is that at that
situation when I usually have those
little my heart speeds up I would
usually take two of those little [ __ ]
babies and Isis and smoke a bunch of pot
that night I let myself work it out you
know I was even found myself sweating at
one point letting my mind work it out
you know like you said before probably
if you're a Christian you know we're not
more perfect we all have flaws you know
yeah and I know that I got something
mentally that's not right I mean if not
I will become a doctor instead of a
stand-up comic sure the chemical balance
is not right when you retell my [ __ ]
stand-up comic so yeah that's not right
but I respect it it's like cocaine now
it's like when you're a rehab and you
come out and you say to yourself I
understand what cocaine is once you
understand that you know what this yeah
I know what cocaine is I know what
heroin is I know what oxycontin is I
know I could smoke 55 joints and live my
life right you know so for me I've
considered going clean but I wouldn't
make it I'm not too [ __ ] oh it's the
weed makes me feel like I'm doing
something I'm not supposed to be doing
so I'm okay with that right it's not
robbing banks it's not breaking into
people's houses and I have people over
the head with a flashlight it just makes
me feel like I'm still sure that little
criminal I was yeah just a weed now I I
have I have nicotine and caffeine for
that very reason because I need to have
some vice there has to absolutely yeah
so you what you do is you pick the worst
one for you you know Lee got on twitch
and you got to play games and stuff like
that yeah starting this weekend Lee was
asking me to play games Lego yes and no
no when I was a kid I didn't have I
didn't like monopoly but after hearing
Rogen one day Robin was hooked Rogan was
[ __ ] addicted to quake it's like 20
hours a night at quake he would go home
just to play quake in those days like
seeing those say it and I would get him
call him for days and what happened dog
I went into a foxhole this one he wasn't
getting high at all nothing
so it was like your whole life is
basically a transfer of addiction
yeah if you have an addictive
personality it's just a transfer
addictive yeah and you end up in the one
that's causes the least for you if if
you're if you're on a healthy path right
if your are not on a healthy path you
wanted a bliss if you came to me you
know listen Joey I don't want to do
coconut oil it's more crack I don't want
to suck [ __ ] [ __ ] dick but I tell
you what I want to do I want to eat
cheeseburger I won't need two
cheeseburgers a day in the middle I have
a [ __ ] slim fair shake lunch sounds
like a dad yeah that's what I want you
to I just want you to be happy yeah
happiness is the whole key to this you
know there's people that take sobriety
and they turn it into being unhappy if
that's the case then find the happy
medium yeah yeah listen 94 I got I got a
the president 90 something and 95 I got
this opportunity become a chronic and
before anything I didn't mental
inventory in those days I used to do the
Abe Lincoln clothes you know you take up
sheet of paper and put a line down the
middle and put the positive effect and
the negative effect yeah and start right
let's be honest here but you got to be
totally honest to do this [ __ ] what is
the effects and I came up with something
I said you know what I'm not gonna stop
someone call this [ __ ] live life
that I'm living going on at a meeting
and then staying sober for three days
and for one day walking around confused
I'm an addict nothin I could do but I
pay what I can I get on stage every
night so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
get on stage every night I'm not a lot
do cocaine for you girl off stage right
and that listen if [ __ ] worked we're
here today are we not here tonight you
have to you have to have your barriers
so you have to do what works for you
eventually and then I saw the movie ray
and they said that he did heroin til 63
and Here I am 44 and I'm like is that
what I want I want to blow man I'm gonna
I want to get successful to continue
doing cocaine so I could quit when I'm
63 that's not our life right because
when you're addicted to something like
that as you know it's a prison yeah it's
a present it's a mental person you will
know that sure so that's that's why I'm
happy that I'm [ __ ] sober you're sober
we deal with these social issues yeah
but we keep them like I hate going to
[ __ ] Hollywood things oh yeah I
basically borderline plant that's it
that's it yeah I'm done like I went to
one because I had done three episodes
they're very nice I said let me go I
took my wife it was a date night you
know when you have a five you're yet you
gotta give your wife a stab and then get
her out of the house if not they just
become a [ __ ] mom and they go into
[ __ ] mommy [ __ ] that talk all the
time you know yeah so I try to take her
out as much as I can and we went and
that's again my back was against the
wall looking for an exit strategy I
couldn't hear what people were saying to
me uh I also just feel so out of place
in Hollywood things like I have no
business at all being there nobody there
yeah it's the Hollywood things are
particularly rough I think they're rough
you have to be okay can I give a little
Hollywood thing in you you did eight
episodes of the show you're obviously
part of the cast can you see me there
you go hey Joey how are you good to see
you and you look at me and go I didn't
ain't episodes of 12 did you do some of
the episodes me I'm like no I'm just
saying the saying I love you like what
are you doing here
I worked on the show by the way I I
could never have that point of view
because I'm always wondering what the
[ __ ] I'm doing I'm doing it yeah why am
I here I did the show right and I still
don't know why man I don't know why I'm
here I can't imagine why the [ __ ] you're
here yeah
you can it's been a pleasure man always
a pleasure what are you working on now I
have a show on who that is is done we
did 20 episodes it's called chance and
we're finished with it but I'm
particularly proud of it I thought it
was really good a couple couple slow
episodes in the beginning but it's just
taking its time and then it warms up
really fun right now I'm doing a show
called the Santa Clarita diet for
Netflix I'm doing this season yeah bad
[ __ ] how many years so far I'd
say
[ __ ] 24 and you believe that
25:25 made me I'm not even totally sure
I think I'm twenty this year yeah do we
get our pensions yeah yeah 55 55 55 I
get my pension that I could go for an
early pension right now if I want to
leave it there I don't want it
though I don't know what maybe this guy
from Denny's Eve I'm still slinging dick
at 55 who gives a [ __ ] oh yeah I got
four kids to put through college I'm
gonna be working until I'm 90 good yeah
there's only you to [ __ ] they'll stop
using it you lose anyway that's right
well at least you looking forward you
look great you two never is great to see
I'm happy you came on the church and
thank you brother yeah I'm gonna promote
anything anytime you want to just talk
anytime you want to get on the house you
know you're welcome a your [ __ ]
families wait to see it don't forget
next Thursday I'm at a levee live in
Huntsville Alabama and then Friday and
Saturday I'm a Nashville zany's two
shows on Friday two shows on Saturday
tickets are on sale right now and that's
basically it I'll see you [ __ ]
Thursday morning don't forget always my
[ __ ] heart on it for your
supplements whether it's alpha brain
shroom tech shoot export shroom tech
immune new mood you know the al jerky
listen I love those guys number two go
to alikom right now press in church I
get 10% off delivered right to your
[ __ ] crib you don't have to leave the
goddamn house and like I said before if
you think I get until you Jitsu or your
Inderjit you want a tough dependable guy
that they can hang off your whatever
fuji sports whether it's a $96 offseason
light one cuz they're lightweight it's
not like you have a [ __ ] some guy
hanging on you even saying these are
lightweight it's like having a t-shirt
on you the elemental ghee is tremendous
the super-ego is tremendous to cycle
point to go to Fuji Sports calm and
press in church BAM and then the right
there [ __ ] I love you I love
eating
I love the [ __ ] [ __ ] and I
love me too but most importantly I love
you [ __ ] see you Thursday
morning tip-top Magoo ready a [ __ ]
stab a [ __ ] in the neck kick
that mealy